bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono vani j
oggi siamo sua madre inverno dovevo
assolutamente giocarlo me l'avete
consigliato adesso andremo a giocarci vi
ringrazio in anticipo perché non so che
non sarà uno spasso
direi di iniziare tra l'altro il menu
fantastico cioè vorrei capire che non si
che banche si tengono le scritte
cioè siamo su binari a quanto pareva
iniziamo iniziamo così c'è un bambino
buongiorno qualche caramella presa il
binario 9 trequarti questo è il motto di
radioterapia maglie successo e riporta
indietro tuo figlio portare e casso cosa
è successo devo portare indietro mio ok
siamo partiti è caduto io sono io sono
questa è quanto sono sexy e lui
combattuto gioco da quando ha aperto il
canale l'unico gioco nel quale ci vedi
allo specchio cazzo che poi tratto
questo non è uno specchio un vetro che
bomba sexy fantastico va beh direi di
andare avanti alla ragazza e non ho ben
capito sinceramente quale losco devo
portare indietro mio figlio ma si è
sparato un ruolo nel vagone di dietro
c'era ok che è successo chiesto
raga cos'è quella roba da gioco che
cazzo e dove potevo premere il tasto
sinistro alla mamma ti saluto ciao ciao
bello mi vedi sono qui
senti un attimo zio arrivato mio figlio
è che dovrebbero essere arrivato mio
figlio ha visto mettendo la mano sul
cuore
io uso la mano oddio no ho capito c'è ma
io che la mano nata ai tempi c'è ma
questo vuol dire che se io posso fare
posso muovere la mano a mio piacimento
eh vabbè ciao ciao bello iorio entro io
entro cliente
apro la porta salve buongiorno senta
mica visto mio figlio che è caduto di
qua devo devo si può fare qui devo
premesso alto sinistro
cosa ho raccolto ho raccolto beh oddio
raga solo manesco raccolto un vectra
temi si vedono le tette mi si vedono
ragazzi sono le tette ed è il primo
videogame o mi posso vedere allo
specchio e del primo video game nel
quale posso vedermi le tette
allora io vado avanti così però c'è un
tipo ii quindi non vado avanti
tranquillo c'è anche una scritta io io
mi sto avvicinando mi sto avvicinando
piano cosa oddio perché sto combinando
rimuovi da testa dal mio corpo cosa devo
fare devono staccargli la testa
amico mio senti un attimo se la smetti
un secondo di vomitare io ti dovrei
staccare la testa che è successo a pif
ti fa una pippa
sei bellissimo cosa sto facendo
fatto sta che ho staccato la testa stu
poveraccio scusami non vuole sentire un
attimo e non era gli age volete una
scritta che mi dice che devo andare
grazie demandando ad andare di là grazie
mille sono sarò la tua la tua guida
attraverso questo inferno
ok e quindi devo andare devo andare in a
grazie mille 6 meglio del tomtom abbassa
che non dici tornare indietro quando
potete per cos'è quello che è quello
mega man mano che si chiama io mi butto
giù senti ceco sestola a cazzo
cos'è sta roba ragazza è raga è una
disco gallina
[Musica]
ok ragazzi a parte gli scherzi c'è una
gallina che sta ballando ed è in disco
sentite io devo provare ad entrare in
qualsiasi cosa succeda senti io so che
sei sballata ti va di ballare stione 4
di mattina ma io devo andare avanti a
cercare il mio figlio apriamo la porta
[Musica]
cos'è mia carica che è successo sono
sono fermate jordi che è successo sono
tornati indietro perfetto la porta non
era questa era l'altra draga cos'è
successo
maledetta gallina io devo passare di qua
fermati devo riuscire la prima porta
perfetto apriti e da allora bastarda
adesso mi ha rotto il cazzo sentirà
arriva mikami a parte fare le uova a
ritmo minimale che cosa dovrei fare qui
io devo tagliargli la testa
beh ce l'ha fatta
non sa come sono fatta ma ce l'ho fatta
ho tagliato la testa alla gancia e
prevedere tenere premuto il tasto del
braga paranormal il colpo di gallina
ok si muove lo stesso anche senza la
testa e io direi di andare avanti
cazzo c'è la mia guida laggiù perfetto
tomtom agli ottavi
lo chiamerò tom da adesso in avanti
perché tomtom si che cosa ogni tanto ci
sono i filmati senza senso agli sul mio
dorso e ti aiuterò ad attraversare
perché la giustizia celestiale va per
magari dargli un pò più di tempo
senti un secondo dato che mi sembri un
incrocio tra una scimmia e gollum non è
che ci abbia tanta fiducia in te
comunque va bene se devo salire in
groppa facciamo pure basta che facciamo
in fretta
senti ma sei sicuro di leggermi no
perché non sono così convinto la sono
caduto che è successo sono caduto
perfetto siamo partiti malissimo
lo sapeva che ruby regev alziamo le mani
dei giorni ci vai così
io li salgo addosso cioè non sono anche
come mai non so perché ma di sacro
addosso vai attraversiamo
attraversiamo la riva la mia zattera in
america cosa sta succedendo
va bene allora il treno si sta
sconquassa sentito secondo raga ma il
mio figlio di preciso dove cazzo è
caduto perché non può farti dieci vagoni
mio dio cos'è quella roba lì
che cazzo c'è un toro c'è un toro perché
c'è un toro nel treno cosa faccia c'è un
toro nel treno mista sembra voglia
caricarmi ma non penso è partito è
partito invece bastardo tiriamo gli
schiaffi al toro va beh cosa devi fare
attenzione a quest'ora gumy carica
sì però allora i casi sono due o è cieco
o è ubriaco no perché non può non
prendermi cioè cazzo guarda io sono
fermo
allora i casi sono tre o dimenticato
l'ultimo ed efficiente però devo
riuscire a farcela raschi ma mai così
bastardo non ce la farei mai mai salhiya
trovai è ok ce l'ho fatta vai così vai
con taglia taglia come se non ci fosse
un domani
apriamo una macelleria taglia come si
deve mai così ho vinto e convinto core
non ho vinto ne manca ancora una praga è
un box totoro è fantastico poi qualcuno
di voi qualcuno di voi che sta vedendo
il video spiega il senso di questo gioco
me lo spiega perché io non ci trovo un
[ __ ] senso però va bene italiano in
coro mai così vai così
beh forse ho vinto
forse ho vinto si sta scomparendo fa
disfa che scompaia seguito da raich a fa
vigeva su storo uno scontro così epico
non sarà mai visto neanche in final
fantasy
ok e direi di aprire raga siamo al
quarto ragone se non mi sbaglio
e ancora non l'ho trovato mio figlio
c'è una sottospecie di cimitero in un
treno ma come cazzo è possibile madonna
questo deve essere il treno più grande
del mondo rag andata al guinness e io
vado avanti non fate caso a me io sono
qui di passaggio
tornate a riposare tranquilli e io devo
andare east i posti dove non vedo niente
già prima era una cosa inquietante
adesso non vedo nulla cos'è un museo e
c'è anche un museo nel tre ragazzi c'è
anche un cinema c'è di tutto
cos'è un cinema cos'è star una chiesa e
una chiesa e un buongiorno
continuate a guardare film tranquilli
non volevo non volevo disturbo
buongiorno a lei come la visione cos'è
non è un film in 3d vero perché non ha
gli occhiali
le dispiace se mi metto qui vicino
perché c'è spazio c'è spazio mi metto
cos'è titanic in 3d è già arrivata la
parte in cui muore
ti ho rovinato ok è rovinato il finale
non scherzavo ok andiamo avanti
e cos'è cos'è sta roba disco cos'è ciao
tom entro nell'oscurità perfetto povera
madre povera madre
tua sorella il demone vuole i tuoi occhi
penso si riferisca al diavolo entra
nell'oscurità entriamo entriamo
nell'oscurità
oddio visto tagliandola campeggio di un
emo haga mi sono tagliato mi sono
tagliato ma si può ma si può essere così
deficienti e successo ragazzo no oddio
reagan sono andato sono andato in botta
sono andato in botta c'è cazzo ragazzi
sono un drogato premesso fate passare il
drogato non vedo più niente perché tira
che è diventato tutto bianco cioè non è
normale sa cos'è fate passare mio dio
fate passare raga sto in volta fatevi
passare o mio di obama tom aiutami dammi
qualcosa
dami cos'è lavori tagliargli la testa a
tom dammi la mano ragazzo lamond io non
mi sta stuprando da abbi pietà di me ti
prego sono fatto di lsd e o mio dio lega
per chi è che succeda
dammi la mano ti prego guarda cosa è
successo guarda il mio braccio e bianco
lanciano ancora le tette almeno quella
ti prego di mi faccio le tetre fa che
cholet e le tette cielo è un traguardo
raga è diventato tutto bianco non so
dissi guarda te c'è guardate non si vede
una mazza cena perché c'è l'effetto
chiuse cosa sta cos'è sta roba ragazzi
cosa sta succedendo
raga dove sono fiero su un treno una
volta tanto tempo fa
raga non dissi è una foglia laga non
distingue più nulla per cos'è una lumaca
c'è una maniglia c'è una maniglia dietro
una lumaca cos'è che ragazzi io mi sto
attaccando alla lumaca con un braccio mi
sta attaccando con un braccio ad una
lumaca e mi sta traghettando da qualche
parte di te
ditemi che cosa c'è di normale
in questa scena io che non vedo un cazzo
una lumaca abnorme una maniglia dietro
la lumaca e io mi ci attende per farmi
trasportare da qualche parte ecco stiamo
arrivando
fortunatamente grazie mille del
passaggio sei stata gentilissima quando
è servizio taxi la prossima volta mi
porta in piazza castello è però vabbè
andiamo avanti e cristiana cazzo ragazzi
sto gioco io più vado avanti più di sei
ragazzi giorno mi sto sentendo stupido
lo sono già di mio normalmente ma
giocando sto gioco lo sto diventando di
più
o mio dio ok ragazzi siamo sì ma cos'era
io io ogni tanto delle visioni
stranissime di gente brutta molto brutta
cos'è c'è un piano c'è un piano di sotto
in un treno e i binari dove cazzo sono
fiducia ai ragazzi c'è un piano di sotto
in un treno se c'è la pianista fa c'era
anche il cinema è probabilmente c'è un
vagone con gardaland da qualche parte
dovevo solo trovarlo buongiorno salve io
sono di passaggio qui e sono ripassati
ragazzi ragazzi cos'è cos'è sta cosa
cosa cazzo è cosa cos'è sta roba
oh mio dio due tette ci sono delle tette
perfetto allora io non so che cos'è sta
roba ma ci sono delle tette cioè a calci
sono delle ai delle pin allora fammi
capire cosa sei hai delle pinne perché
hai la testa di un cigno
oh mio dio cos'è questo proprio ragazzi
cos'è c'è io sto gioco non lo sto
capendo cioè no mi carica come alto a
bastardo allora anche the dawn salienti
in groppa se è brutto a dirsi ma devo
farlo è mai così vai così vai così
taglia la coltellata fai vedere a kratos
di che sei capace
vai così vai così mamma mia che botta
raga lo sto facendo sanguinare brutto
stronzo
ok ti taglio anche la testa bastard ora
ti taglia la testa
ok è fatta dovrei dovrei avercela fatta
dovrei avercela fatta se non ho visto
male se girata brutta stronza co
tagliato tota lla bastarda ho vinto io
e adesso che adesso vinto però vi non ho
vinto devo tagliarli probabilmente anche
il bene mi sta caricando sta caricando a
novi raga non mi vede non mi vede e non
si sa come riesce a caricarmi va bene
allora io ti taglio anche il pene ti
taglio anche perché è successo dove 66
quando ancora vivo e anche madonna mia
santissima cosa devo fare per ucciderti
un bazooka qualcuno ce l'ha no perché
non ci riesco ragazzi ci è impossibile
ha vinto cazzo se ho vinto
ci ho messo un secolo non mi chiedete
che cosa è successo non mi chiedete chi
ho appena affrontato non lo so raga vedo
mio figlio non ci posso credere al mio
dio come cazzo hai fatto a farti tutti
sti 12.000 vagoni come hai fatto
mi spieghi che da come mi spieghi come
cazzo sei caduto c'è mio dio è finito
così
raga io non so che cosa appena giocato
non lo so non voglio che nessuno di voi
me lo spieghi non lo voglio sapere non
lo voglio sapere
io concludo qui come al solito se il
video è piaciuto lasciato un commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook come
non i video trovate nella descrizione
sera se traggono iscritti iscrivetevi
noi ci vediamo un prossimo video bella
ragazzi
[Musica]